Write in simplified
exponential form.
And we have a product of
a bunch of things here.
6 times 7 times 6 times 9 times
2 to the fourth times 2
times 6 squared times 9.
So a good place to start is to
just group the things that are
of the same base.
And then maybe we can combine
their exponents.
And let's see if we can simplify
it from there.
Let's just go in order
of the bases.
Let's start with the 2's.
So we have a 2 to
the fourth here.
And then we have times 2.
You could view that as times
2 to the first if you like.
Let me write that there.
So you have to 2 to the
fourth times 2.
I'll just rewrite it as 2 to the
first. So we did our 2's.
The next largest number,
or the next largest
base, are the 6's.
We have a 6 right there.
I'll write it as 6 to the first.
Times another 6 or
times another 6 to the
first right there.
Then we have a 6 squared
over here.
So times 6 squared.
I'm really just rearranging
this product out here.
Then the next number that we
have here, the next largest
one, we have a 7.
We only have one 7 there.
So I'll just write times 7.
And then finally, we have
a couple of 9's.
I'll write it as 9 to the one,
then we have another 9.
Times 9 to the one, or
we could just write
that as 9 times 9.
Now, let's merge the bases.
Or let's merge the products
of these bases raised to
different exponents.
You have 2 to the fourth power
times 2 to the first power.
This is going to be the
same thing as 2 to
the 4 plus 1 power.
Or 2 to the fifth power.
Then you have your 6's.
So 6 to the first times 6 to the
first times 6 squared is
the same thing as 6 to
that 1 plus 1 plus 2.
Or 6 to the fourth power.
Then we have that 7 there.
Nothing really you can
do to simplify that.
Times that 7.
And then we have a 9 times
a 9, which is 9 squared.
Or you can think about it as 9
to the first times 9 to the
first, add the exponents,
9 squared.
So depending on how you want to
do this problem, the people
who actually wrote this problem,
this is what they
wanted, they viewed this as
simplified exponential form.
We've combined the same bases
raised to different powers.
So you could stop here.
But if you really want to get
it down to kind of the real
simplest form.
What you could essentially do
is break everything down to
their prime factors.
And then have those raised
to exponents and then
merge them even more.
Let me show you what
I'm talking about.
So this 6 to the fourth here.
Let me keep it the same color.
So we have the 2 to the fifth,
let me just write that there.
But the 6 to the fourth, I could
rewrite 6 as 2 times 3
to the fourth.
6 to the fourth is the exact
same thing is that.
Then we have the times 7.
Then we have the 9 squared.
But 9 we can rewrite
as 3 squared
and all of that squared.
All did here is I rewrote the
6 as 2 times 3 and I rewrote
the 9 as 3 times 3
or as 3 squared.
I want to keep the color
codes the same way.
So we had the 2 to the fifth.
Now, what's 2 times
3 to the fourth?
Well here's an exponent
property.
If you take the product of two
things and it's to a power,
that's the same thing
as 2 to the fourth
times 3 to the fourth.
And then you have this 7 here.
So I essentially just
raised both of
these guys to the fourth.
Because their product is being
raised to the fourth power.
And then you have times 3
squared, but you have 3
squared and then that squared.
So it's going to be 3 to
the 2 times 2 power.
So times 3 to the fourth.
So now we have more bases
we can merge.
We have these 2's here.
2 to the fifth times 2 to
the fourth, what's that?
Well that's 2 to the 5 plus 4.
That's 2 to the ninth power.
Then you have your
3's over here.
Let me do that in green.
You have 3 to the fourth and 3
to the fourth, what's that
going to be?
That's going to be times 3 to
the 4 plus fourth power, or 3
to the eighth power.
And then finally, you have this
7 sitting over there.
So if you really wanted to break
things down to their
prime factors and kind of have
the the least bases here, you
can view this is even a more
simplified exponential form
than what the question writers
originally wanted.
So you could get down all the
way to 2 to the ninth times 3
to the eighth times 7, which
is the same thing is that,
which is the exact same
thing as that.